[Music]
in half a century of trying to help
prevent Wars there's one question that
never leaves me how do we deal with
extreme violence without using force in
return when you're faced with brutality
whether it's a child facing a bully in
the playground or domestic violence or
on the streets of Syria today facing
tanks and shrapnel what's the most
effective thing to do fight back given
use more force this question how do I
deal with the bully without becoming a
thug in return has been with me ever
since I was a child I remember because I
was about 13 glued to a grainy
black-and-white television in my parents
living room as Soviet tanks rolled into
Budapest and kids not much older than me
we're throwing themselves at the tanks
and getting moaned down and I rushed
upstairs and started packing my suitcase
and my mother came up and said what on
earth are you doing and I said I'm going
to Budapest and she said what on earth
for
and I said kids are getting killed there
there's something terrible happening and
she said don't be so silly and I started
to cry
and she got it she said okay I see it's
serious you're much too young to help
you need training I'll help you but just
unpack your suitcase
and so I got some training and went and
worked in Africa during most of my
twenties but I realized that what I
really needed to know I couldn't get
from training courses I wanted to
understand how violence how oppression
works and what I've discovered since is
this bullies used violence in three ways
they use political violence to
intimidate physical violence to
terrorize and mental or emotional
violence to undermine and only very
rarely in very few cases does it work to
use more violence northen Mandela went
to jail believing in violence on 27
years later he and his colleagues had
slowly and carefully honed the skills
the incredible skills that they needed
to turn one of the most vicious
governments the world has known
into a democracy and they did it in a
total devotion to non-violence they
realized that using the force against
force doesn't work so what does work
over time I've collected about a half
dozen methods that do work cause there
many more
that do work and that are effective and
the first is that the change that has to
take place has to take place here inside
me it's my response my attitude to
oppression that I've got control over
that I can do something about and what I
need to develop is self-knowledge to do
that that means I need to know how I
tick when I collapse where my formidable
points are
where my weaker points are when do I
give in what will I stand up for and
meditation or self-inspection is one of
the ways of get is not the only one one
of the ways of gaining this kind of
inner power and my heroine here like
Satish is is long son su Chi in Burma
she was leading a group of students on a
protest in the streets of Rangoon they
came around a corner faced with a row of
machine guns and she realized straight
away that the soldiers with their
fingers shaking on the triggers were
more scared than the student protesters
behind her but she told the students to
sit down and she walked forward with
such calm and such a clarity and such
total lack of fear that she could walk
right up to the first gun put her hand
on it and lower it and no one got killed
so that's what the mastery of fear can
do not only faced with machine guns but
if you if you meet a knife fight in the
street that we have to practice so what
about our fear I have a little mantra my
fear grows fat on the energy I feed it
and if it grows very big it probably
happens so we all know the three o'clock
in the morning syndrome when something
you've been worrying about wakes you up
I see a lot of people and for an hour
you toss and turn it gets worse and
worse and by 4 o'clock you're pinned to
the pillow by a monster this big the
only thing to do is to get up make a cup
of tea
and sit down with the fear like a child
beside you you're the adult the fear is
the child and you talk to the fear and
you ask it what it wants what it needs
how can this be made better how can the
child feel stronger and you make a plan
and you say okay now we're going back to
sleep half past seven we're getting up
and that's what we're going to do I had
one of these 3:00 a.m. episodes on
Sunday paralyzed with fear are coming to
talk to you so I got I did the thing I
got up made the cup of tea sat down with
it digital and I'm here still poorly
paralyzed but I'm here I said that's
fear what about anger
wherever there's injustice there's anger
but anger is like gasoline and if you
spray it around and somebody lights a
match
you've got an inferno but anger as an
engine in an engine is powerful if we
can put our anger inside an engine it
can drive us forward it can get us
through the dreadful moments and it can
give us real inner power and I learned
this in my work with nuclear weapon
policymakers because at the beginning I
was so outraged at the dangers they were
exposing us to that I just wanted to
argue and blame and make them wrong
totally ineffective in order to develop
a dialogue for change we have to deal
with our anger it's okay to be angry
with the the thing the nuclear weapons
in this case but it is hopeless to me
angry with the people they are human
beings just like us and they're doing
what they think is best and that's the
basis on which we have to talk with them
so that's the third
anger and it brings me to the crux of
what's going on
what I perceive is going on in the world
today which is that last century was
top-down power with still government's
telling people what to do this century
there's a shift it's bottom up or
grassroots power
it's like mushrooms coming through
concrete it's people joining up with
people as Bundy just said miles away to
bring about change and peace direct
spotted quite early on that local people
in areas of very hot conflict know what
to do they know best what to do
so historic gets behind them to do that
and the kind of thing they're doing is
demobilizing militias rebuilding
economies resettling refugees even
liberating child soldiers and they have
to risk their lives almost every day to
do this and what they realized is that
using violence in the situation's they
operate in is not only less humane but
it's less effective than using methods
that connect people with people that
rebuild and I think that the US military
is finally beginning to get this up to
now their counterterrorism policy has
been to kill insurgents at almost any
cost
and if civilians get in the way that's
written as collateral damage and this is
so infuriating and humiliating for the
population of Afghanistan
that it makes recruitment for al-qaeda
very easy when people are so disgusted
by for example the burning of the Koran
so the training of the troops has to
change and I think there are signs that
it is beginning to change the the
British military have always been much
better at this but there was there's one
magnificent example for them to take
their cue from and that's a brilliant US
left-handed colonel called Chris Hughes
and he was leading his men down the
streets of Najaf in Iraq actually and
suddenly people were pouring out of the
houses on either side of the road
screaming yelling furiously angry and
surrounded these very young troops who
were completely terrified didn't know
what was going on couldn't speak Arabic
and Chris Hughes strode into the middle
of the throng with his what weapon above
his head pointing at the ground and he
said kneel and these huge soldiers with
their backpacks and their body armor
wobbled to the ground and complete
silence fell and after about two minutes
everybody moved aside and went home now
that to me is wisdom in action in the
moment that's what he did and it's
happening everywhere now you don't
believe me have you asked yourselves why
and how so many dictatorships have
collapsed over the last 30 years
dictatorships in Czechoslovakia East
Germany Estonia Latvia Lithuania Mali
Madagascar
Poland the Philippines Serbia Slovenia I
could go on and now Tunisia and Egypt
and this hasn't just happened you know a
lot of it is due to a book written by an
80 year old man in Boston gene sharp he
wrote a book called from dictatorship to
democracy with 81 methodologies for
nonviolent resistance and it's been
translated into 26 languages it's flown
around the world and it's being used by
young people and older people everywhere
because it works it's effective so this
is what gives me hope not just hope this
is what makes me feel very positive
right now because finally human beings
are getting it we're getting we're
getting practical doable methodologies
to answer my question how do we deal
with the bully without becoming a thug
we're using the kind of skills that I've
outlined inner power development of
inner power through self-knowledge
recognizing and working with our fear
using anger as a fuel cooperating with
others banding together with others
courage and most importantly commitment
to active non-violence now I don't just
believe in non-violence I don't have to
believe in it I see evidence everywhere
of how it works and I see that we
ordinary people can do what on Sun Tzu
Chi and Gandhi and Mandela did
we can bring to an end for bloodiest
century that humanity has ever known and
we can organize to overcome oppression
by opening our hearts as well as
strengthening this incredible resolve
and this open heartedness is exactly
what I have experienced in the entire
organization of this gathering since I
got here yesterday thank you
[Applause]
you